du sport du cyclisme avec le tour de
france à l'issue de la quatrième étape
disputée entre laval et blois le maillot
jaune est toujours sur les épaules de
l'estonien kirsi pew étape sans trop de
problèmes pour les coureurs ce soir jean
marie leblanc le directeur général du
tour de france évoqué la situation de
richard virenque comme celle d'un
coureur comme les autres une sorte de
climat de retour à la normale voulu avec
obstination par plusieurs équipes qui
firent parler d'elle beaucoup l'année
dernière pour cause de dopage
parmi ces équipes festina reportage
florent gautreau philippe deslandes les
mêmes gestes à la même cadence les mêmes
supporters l'équipe festina est toujours
là et laurent brochard signe autant
d'autographes que l'année dernière
cette popularité c'est ce qui a décidé
miguel rodriguez de patron des montres
festina a continué d'investir dans le
cyclisme à hauteur de 20 millions de
francs par an pour le plus grand bonheur
des supporters
laurent et les pays bas ont été pris à
partie mais toutes les équipes
c'était la même
cinéma est confiant que eux ont payé
puisque les autres dernière on n'aurait
pas dû les esprits il ya un an la
découverte d'un système de dopage
organisé avait entraîné l'exclusion de
l'équipe festina du tour 98 aujourd'hui
virenque du loup et du fou ont changé
d'équipé steffens a arrêté sa carrière
et pascal hervé n'a pas été invité à
faire le tour chez festina on cherche à
gommer se passer on n'est pas pour
baptiser aujourd'hui on a oublié ce qui
s'est passé l'année dernière et puis on
l'a oublié
dire qu'il faut nous en parler pour
françois rappel du passé faisons table
rase
l'équipe du fabricant de montres a fait
sa révolution d'un jeune coureur souvent
inconnus du grand public ont pris la
place des stars les visages ont changé
les objectifs aussi l'équipe de ma doit
se satisferait d'une simple victoire
d'étape
en fait si festina est toujours là c'est
que le retour sur investissement est
payant
malgré les affaires malgré la modestie
de la nouvelle équipe les ventes de
montres ne cesse d'augmenter
aujourd'hui entre laval et blanc
allaient festina sont restés discrets
l'étape la plus rapide de toute
l'histoire du tour courue à plus de 50
km heure s'est terminée au sprint avec
la première victoire cette année sur le
tour de çi pollinique devant l'allemande
zabel qui se spécialise dans les 2e
place un peu à l'écart